hey guys beat here it's going to be my
ten things you might have missed in Twin
Peaks season 3 episode 11 if you haven't
watched it yet this is your spoiler
warning you're going to want to click
away so yeah this was a fantastic
episode like I talked about in the recap
and review and there were a ton of
things that popped out on the second
watch some of this stuff I saw on mine
after the fact - so let's jump right
into it the first one I teased in my
other video I didn't want to go down the
rabbit hole I talked about the staircase
and seeing it before where we saw the
three woodsmen and vortex you know after
Gordon was there for a minute and this
is something that I've been waiting for
it to pop up because it was in that it's
happening again trailer that came out
right before season 3 started so in the
trailer we see someone it looks like
someone's ascending the staircase right
but there's obviously no woodsman there
in that part so this is the location
that we haven't been yet that but we'll
probably going which it makes it extra
exciting now a lot of people thought it
might be at the Palmers house it is
definitely not the staircase at the
Palmers house in my opinion if you look
at them side-by-side they're set up
differently if you look at screen grabs
of this one you can see the walls are
kind of greyish green and there's some
like patched painting on it and someone
on reddit actually lightened up the part
where there's a little colorburst like
they're shown a negative almost at first
where everything looks white and right
before it cuts back to Gordon there's a
little flash of light and what people
are saying is this is the same wallpaper
as the picture that old lady Tremont
gives Laura and fire walk with me when
you see this comparison here I didn't
make this I just grabbed it from a
reddit thread and it looks pretty
compelling also in the bright version of
it it almost looks like there is a well
there's definitely a shape on the wall
but it almost looks like a mushroom
cloud and as I mentioned in my recap and
review to me it looks like the guy on
the left side is holding a gas can so
there's a lot going on in this little
image and I'll leave it at there for
now but yeah it's definitely worth
looking at a lot closer one more quick
thing about this is that some people are
speculating that this may lead to the
meeting room above the convenience store
and I think that that is definitely a
possibility but I don't know how to draw
any more parallels about that right at
this moment it's just a good idea that
sounds good so definitely worth a little
bit of speculating on that for sure
second thing you might have missed was
that the woman that Stephens hiding and
the staircase with is in fact played by
alicia witt who was Kirsten Hayward and
has to assume that she still is who was
Donna's little sister one of her little
sisters that we all remember from
episode 8 playing the piano so why she's
in the staircase with Stephen and why
Stephen is over in the apartment and why
Becky shot up the front door is all
still a mystery the third thing you
might have missed her neighbor who pops
out to tell Becky that she no longer is
there like that they just left is
actually a cameo as well the neighbor is
played by Lauren twos I think that's how
you pronounce it te w es and she is
familiar maybe if you watch The Love
Boat she was on that TV show back in the
day the first thing you might have
missed was Gordon shaking hand and I
honestly did saw this brought up a
couple places and then it hit me I
remembered this from the original from
season 2 now first let me say I'm not
sure if this is related but this
happened back in episode 20 there was an
older woman sitting at the double are
eating a slice of cherry pie and we see
her hands start to shake later in the
same episode Cooper is looking out a
window at the police station I believe
he was looking at the I'll cave stuff
and he was trying to think and he starts
to shake and then one last time Pete
Martel as he's wiping a tear from his
eye as he's watching Audrey and jacket
in his plane his hand starts to like
shake like crazy a lot like how Gordon's
was so that could be related it could be
a callback or this could just be the
after
facts of what happened to Gordon when he
was at the site so the next thing that
you might have missed is something that
I saw on Twitter like almost right away
it seems like after the credits rolled
but in the scene where the kids are
playing catch the older one who has the
speaking role is actually mark frost son
Travis so that's a pretty interesting
little thing so yeah if you look at the
credits it says that he's boy playing
catch and it is Travis brought the sixth
thing you might have missed is and this
I caught on the second time when I
watched you know after I already knew
what was going to happen in the episode
when I saw Tony looking in on Bushnell
and dougie coupe in case you hadn't
thought about it the events as they
played out at the end was the mention
brothers not killing dougie but actually
befriending him that means that the
responsibility for killing dougie coupe
is squarely on Tony Sinclar shoulders
remember that was a straight order from
Duncan Todd if this doesn't work then
you're responsible for killing him so at
the end of the episode we now know that
dougie coupe has a new assassin on its
trail and we're going to have to wait
and see how that plays out the 7th thing
you might have missed was that the
numbers on the photo that are a ruse
Davenport's arm they may have been
doctored in some way a lot of people
pointed this out I mean this team like I
said in the recap and review it's kind
of weird
all the way around like the way that
they hold the picture the way that she
mounts the numbers well a few people
pointed out that under the very first
set of numbers there's basically like a
clean spot so the thinking here is that
maybe Albert doctored the photo or
literally changed the numbers before he
took a second photo to see what happens
with Diane
I can't tell 100% I mean it looks like
there's other weird spots and the N
numbers or smudge so let's discuss that
in the comments the a thing you might
have missed and really this is kind of
this is kind of superfluous in a way
because it happened
on Twitter but maybe when you were
watching and you saw Carl in the Carl
mobile and everything else you might
have had an idea that he could be a book
house boy so someone on Twitter had that
same idea and they asked mark frost
basically if he was an honorary member
and mark frost responded that he is an
original member so that is pretty
massive
now I didn't personally do the math on
the ages and everything else I mean I
know the book house boys came into
existence around the time of World War
two so I'm just going to let all that
slide I'm not even gonna fact-check it
because it mark frost said it right so
that is pretty interesting it gives a
little context to that whole sequence
with Shelley there and yeah like I said
I can't get an upper call rod I want
call rod involved in the everything and
I'm super excited to learn that he is
most likely an original member of the
book house boys the nice thing you might
have missed it was that the piano player
was not credited and there was a lot of
talk after the episode because he played
a pretty big part there and you know
people were wondering if it was Angelo
Badalamenti in which I'm sure I just
split heard that name himself you know
the guy who composes all the music and
it does look like him so with no credits
everyone was kind of trying to figure
out who this guy was and a couple people
recognized him a couple of his friends
and it turns out that this guy's name is
Robert smokey mild and of course all the
actors have to file a nondisclosure
agreement so they can't say who they are
until they actually show up on screen so
he heard about it and then some people
talked to him and he was he got called
at the last minute I guess and he said
that you know he sat down at the piano
and David Lynch directed him and it was
the most interesting personal and deep
way and he said he created a mental
picture for him to play soft romantic
Italian music was his eyes closed and he
did a couple takes so that was it it's
also interesting to note that he didn't
hear the song that he's playing here
like it hadn't actually been written yet
so she was basically set the mood for
him and he sat there and it turned out
great I think so very cool and the tenth
thing you might have missed is one that
I have mentioned in the recap and review
by wanting to bring it up again
whenever detective Mack Lee calls for
backup he tells them the address and it
is on Sycamore we're guessing it's
Sycamore Street or Sycamore Road
whatever he doesn't say but you know
it's callback and possibly a tie-in to
Glastonbury Grove which is a stand the
Sycamores definitely interesting and
someone asked in the comments I can't
remember who the name was at this point
but they mentioned that didn't we see
something about Sycamore in Las Vegas -
whenever dougie coupe first got driven
out of Rancho Rosa with Jade and I just
went back and watched that scene and
sure enough that was the case so we have
a reference to Sycamore in Buckhorn Las
Vegas and Twin Peaks itself so that's it
there was a couple other ones that I
wasn't a hundred percent able to verify
I don't really know how I feel about the
stuff with the staircase as far as the
flower pattern I mean obviously that's
pretty huge if that is the same
wallpaper but the images I have of it I
can't make that out what at all so I
don't know of course in the photo I used
I mean it definitely looks like it so
it's just a matter of whether that's a
good photo or not we never really got a
full story about that I mean obviously
she had Laura hang that in a room the
door was open and then we saw Laura sort
of passed through that at one point but
we know we know we never saw Laura in
the room above the convenience store so
what does it actually mean that is where
the speculation comes in I guess but
yeah this episode was awesome I watched
it a bunch of really watched a bunch and
you know some of the scenes several
times
was doing the recap and review and
taking notes and um yeah I mean things
are getting closer I mean in the
timeline were two days away from this
event that's supposed to happen a
Jackrabbits palace so I'm pumped up for
what's to come please like the video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already check out
my other videos
people have been asking about the log
Lady intros and I will eventually do
that the actual log Lady video didn't
get a lot of views though and it seems
like when I make current events like
things that are going on with the show
those are doing better right now so I'll
have to find a point to fit it in what
I'm thinking about now is maybe
something about the map there's a really
cool theory about dougies time being
slightly off after passing through the
mob zone which I might look at and also
the new episode titles are kind of fun
to guess about too so maybe I'll do like
a video about those things on Saturday
yeah that's it make sure you follow me
on Twitter and my other social media
account thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon